[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا النشره ننتقل الى
السودان و كلمه لرئيس مجلس السيادي عبد
الفتاح البرهان
القوات المسلحه
السودان
وبيحموا
اهل السودان
احنا بنحييون ابو الليل نحن وانتم كلنا
قضيتنا واحده قضيتنا الوطن
وحمايه شعبه وحمايه ارضه دي قضيتنا لابنه
زايد فيها
ولا عندنا اي كلام في كل زول دي قضيتو
احنا بنقول لهم
ربنا
في كل مكان
اخواننا المرابطين اذا كانوا في الشركه
وفي الغريب او في الجنوب بيدوا نفس
الرساله اللي انتم كلكم اديتوها وهتقدوها
ونحنا اديناها وهنظل حاملين لهذه الرساله
وهذه الامانه
نحن طبعا في القوات المسلحه في السنين
الماضيه دي عملنا عمل كله يخدم مصلحه
القوات المسلحه
ويخدم مصلحه التحول ان احنا كلنا بنعيشه
من 2019 تحول اللي هبه من اجل الشعب
السوداني عشان كذا نحن بنوعد الشعب
السوداني ان احنا في صفه
وكل حاجه تحول دون تحقيق تطلع
معه
ينال مبتغاه وينال ما خرج من اجله من اجل
تغيير حقيقي
من اجل تغيير حقيقي تغيير ما مصطنع تغيير
ما فيه اي جهه كسبانه غير هذا الشعب
والشباب السودانيين اللي طلعوا ضحوا نحنا
كلنا شايفين انه مو عارفين نوم نحن نقول
ان احنا معاكم
لكن كل شيء يتم الطرق الصحيحه
اللي بره الامان نحن في الجيش ما قاعدين
ساكت في السنين الماضي
القوات ونجهزها بكل ما يمكن ان يعينه في
انها تنفذ مهامه اهتمينا بكل شيء اذا كان
بالفرد وتحسين البيئه
وهو شخصيا
لكن نحن مصممين انه هذا الجندي
انه يؤدي وقادر انه يشتغل بدون ما يكون
عنده حاجه شاغله بدون ما يكون عنده اي
تفكير في انه واولاده خلاهم وين بياخذوا
جنوبي بتعالجوا كيف وبيشربوا جنوا وغازات
ولابس شنو مسلح بجنوب وقاتل الجنوب قاتل
الجنوب
عشان كده بدينا بدينا في اصلاح رقبتنا في
اصلاح مؤسستنا العسكريه من التنظيم من فوق
لغايه اخر جندي
منهج الدخول لي الكليه الحربيه كله صلحناه
الناس اللي بيسمعوا الاصلاح بتاع الموصل
العسكريه ما يخافوا نحن بنصلحه بالطريقه
اللي انت مكينه وتقويها وتخليها هي وحده
فعلا جيش سوداني حقيقي بيحمي السودان
وبيدافع السودان
مع نسمح للجهه تعبث بالقوات المسلحه
ده كلام نحنا بنقول لكم
قاعدين
حق الشعب السوداني والشعب السوداني يستعمل
هذه البلد لذلك
ما في تسويه ثنائيه نحن صحيح في واحده في
ورقه قدمت نحنا عملنا عليه ابو لحظاتنا
الجيش
كرمته
تحفظ للجيش الاستقلالته جيشنا
جيشنا دايزه ما دخل وسوس اذا ما دخلوا سوس
من بعض السياسيين والهتان السياسيين من
انه ما يتدخلوا في شارع القوات المسلحه
ونتكلم بصراحه
نحن الشراكه الفضيناه في 25 اكتوبر مع
الحريه والتغيير لن دخلت جوه الجيش
عساكرنا عشان يعملوا عملها قدام نحن ولينا
احسن
ارجوكم من عندنا مثل
قالوا عم من فضل الله بورما
في بدايه
تغيير او تصحيح المسار في 25 اكتوبر
نحنا ثاني الكلام ده بقول الله
فاتحزرنا جهات معين
طالما فيه نفس الروح
نحنا ما عندنا ولاء ولا عندنا انتماء
انتماءنا للجيش ده انا دخلنا الكليه
الحربيه سنه 80 الكلام اللي قال اخونا نحن
عشناوه سنه 80 في سرير رابعه كان معانا
المرحوم كان الفكي كافي من لقوه المرحوم
عبد الحميد حسن نافع من سنجه معنا اخونا
علي هذا هارون من نيابه معانا اخونا عبد
الحميد عبد الرحمن عبد الرحمن
خالد حسن مختار من الجزيره او من البطانه
معانا اخونا عبد القادر عبد القادر من 24
قرش كنا كلنا السودان ساكنين في عنبر واحد
ما بنعرف
يجمعنا اشكال كذا تجمعنا القوات المسلحه
عشان كده هذه الصفه وهذه القوميه نحن بدنا
قوميه القوات المسلحه هي القوميه
السودانيه
ولان لهذه القوات لن يتبدل وحنضحي عشانه
نحن
سنمضي الى ما يحقق استقرار السودان
سنمضي الى ما يحقق وحده السودان
نحن صحيح تم التفاهمات بيننا وبين بعض
اخواننا في قيادات الحريه والتغيير نحن
عشنا فيهم هذه الروح
والتزموا قدامنا انهم ما بيعملوا للجسم
معين هم بيعملوا من اجل السودان
احنا معاكم سواء والتزموا قدامنا انه ماذا
يرجعوا ثاني مافي حريه اداره ترجع ده كلام
الليله ما في حزب كان مشارك في الفتره
السابقه احنا شغل السودان كله السودانيين
كلهم نحب نكرر دعوتنا اليوم
البلد ما تضيعوا البلد في هذا النزاع
النزاع الغير محدود ما عنده احد كله زين
متمسك برايه
بالطريقه اللي احنا بنمشي واذا قلنا كلنا
نروح نجيبه وناخذها
عشان كده في رؤيا واحده نقعد فيها نشرحه
نصلحها اذا فيها عوجه نعدي لها اذا فيها
حاجه ما مزبوطه لكن كونه نتمنع نقول الله
ان احنا نمشي ونحن نحنا ما جاتنا الورقه
وعدلناها القوى السياسيه وتعدله عشان
بلدنا يا جماعه
احنا لينا ثلاثه سنين ماشيين متراجعين
انظروا الى شوارعنا انظروا الى مصانعنا
انظروا الى مزارعنا كلها اصابه ضرر واصابه
خراب كله ناتج من تمتروس كله اخوانه
سياسيه نحن نمشي ورانا نعمل حلول احاديه
ما بيغلبنا لكن احنا دارين توافق دارين
توافق محمي محمي ونحنك قوات مسلحه زي ما
اخونا ما قال اخونا حضره الصول دايرين
مدنيه يا حريف الجيش ده ما في جهه ثانيه
عليها وحارسنا مش نحن
كلكم انتم ثاني انا بمشي محمد عثمان بيمشي
وانتم قاعدين
احنا شغالين فيه
نحن ماشيين قوات مسلحه
جيده نزعل لانه توافق مع كل جيراننا مع
اخواننا في جنوب السودان نزل عشان نحل
مشكله التبيين مع اخواننا الاثيوبيين اول
حاجه احنا بنهنيهم قال ان هم حصل بينهم
توافق نحن بنقول لهم ده امل
في مصلحه السودان لانه نحن متضررين من كله
نزاع ينشا في اي وحده وسندعم هذا الاتفاق
ايضا سنفعى لانه نساوي مشكلتنا معاهم
بالطرق السلميه اذا كانت الحدود وبسب
النهضه وانا في جنوب السودان
بتاعه الحدود كلها نحن ما في فرق بيننا
وبينه ان احنا كلنا سعد واحد لذلك انه
علاقتنا مع دول الاقليم مع دول الجوار
تطبع علاقه متزنه علاقه بتاعه منفعه
متبادله وعلاقه ما يشوف اي توتر
الصحيحه جيش بلد ويحافظ عليها نحن بنحييكم
وبنقول لكم تاكدوا تماما انه نحن وانتم
سوا كلنا يد واحده ضد عدو هذا السودان
نحنا وانتم كلنا يد واحده ضد عدو القوات
المسلحه
القوات المسلحه دي عادوا بالنسبه لنا مين
نسينا نقولوا قدام الناس
ابعدوا من الجيش بعيد
دي البوصله حقتنا في علاقتنا مع القوى
السياسيه مع القوه المتبعيه عشان كده
المره اللي فاتت حزرنا الناس وحذرنا
الاسلاميه لانه بدو ينخروا وبده يتدخلوا
في هذه الجيش يقولوا امشوا بعيد ما عندكم
طريقه تاني تجد تدخلوا ولا ترجعوا تركبوا
في ظهر الجيش عشان تحكم وما في ما في جهه
احنا ظاهر ولا اي زول عشان الحكم قاعد
ماشا الدغري التزمت نحن كلنا نحميها
احنا عندنا عهود وعندنا مواسير بن راعيها
وبنحفظها
معاكم واحد انا مع الشعب السوداني ان نحن
نمضي في ما يحقق له امنواره نحن الحكومه
الجايه هذه متوقع انها تكون الحكومه من
المستغلين الغير منتمين الاحزاب ده كلامنا
بنقول طوالي قال له والله بلد نزل هذا
تمشي ومرحبتنا الانتقاليه تنجح ما تجينا
حساب راجع ثاني لتحكم ما ندخل في نفس
المحافظاتك دخلنا فيها زمان نحن الورقه
قلبي نمشي فيها ونبقى فيها هذه ما على شان
جاء معينه لا يقحت ولا اشياء معينه دي
للسودان السودان
نحن بنحييكم وبنشود على ايديكم واحد واحد
ونقول نحن معكم ونحن فيكم نحن لو ما
بنلاقيه في الموقف ده ولا ابن نجيزات
في هذه الدنيا كان زمان نكون انتصرنا
لكن الحمد لله
بس هذا الزي زي القوات المسلحه هذا الزي
هو شرف بين لينا نحن بدنا نرتديه لانه مثل
وحده السودان بيمثل ع العمود الفقري
والقلب النابض اللي منه بيضخ الدم في
شرايين السودان المختلفه دي كله مكان هسه
الان اللوحه اللي قدامنا دي لو ايزل عليها
بالقهوه
الجنسيه
[موسيقى]
فقط تحيه لكم تحيه للشعب السوداني بارك
الله فيكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
الاساسيه هي حمايه الوطن وشعبه وارضه وقال
القوات المسلحه لن تسمح لاي جهه بالعبت
بالجيش او محاوله تفكيك تعاهد برهان
بالسعيا لتحقيق تطلعات الشعب البرهان اكد
ايضا عدم وجود ما يسمى بالتسويه الثنائيه
مشيرا الى ان انهاء الشراكه مع المكون
المدني بسبب سعيه للتدخل في شؤون الجيش
وحذر البرهان بعض السياسيين الذين يحاولون
التحريض على الجيش مؤكدا ان هذه المحاولات
لن تنجح البرهان اشار الى ان استمرار
انقسام القوه السياسيه وغياب التوافق يضر
المؤسسات السودانيه وقال ان السودان يسعى
لحل الازمه مع اديس ابابا سواء المتعلقه
بالحدود او سد النهضه وذلك عبر الحوار
اذا نبدا من اخر المستجدات مستجدات
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه واخر
التطورات النتائج هناك
[موسيقى]
الديمقراطيه
بمجلس الشيوخ عن ولايه نيفادا الحاسمه بعد
فوزها على الجمهوريه
مصر العربيه
يعود الى نائبه الرئيس
ديسمبر في جورجيا تحدث وفرقا في النتيجه
الديمقراطيه
النتيجه تشير الى ان الناخبين
اتجاه المناهض الديمقراطيه وليست امداد
في مجلس النواب لا تزال عمليات الفرز
مستمره لكن يبدو ان الجمهوريين اقرب
للسيطره ولو باغلبيه بسيطه ويفصلهم عن ذلك
سبعه مقاعد فقط فمن اصل 218 مقعدا وهو
الرقم المطلوب للفوز حصل الجمهوريون حتى
الان على 2011 مقعدا في ما حصل ديمقراطيون
على 2005
في كمبودي لحضور قمه شرق اسيا سعادته
بنتيجه الانتخابات بين اضافه ان نتيجه
الانتخابات اعززت وضعه سياسي
للعاملين المقبلين من فتره الرئاسيه مؤكدا
انها تركيزه ينصب الان على نتيجه انتخابات
مجلس الشيوخ في ولايه جورجيا
معنا من بيروت استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
الدكتور سامي نادر دكتور اهلا بك الكل كان
يتحدث هل هذه الانتخابات استفتاء على فتره
العامين التي حكم بها بيدن وكذلك الازمات
التي تحيط بامريكا لكن يبدو ان الرجل
مرتاح الان وان عامين قادمين قد يكونن
اهيا مما كان متوقعا باشتياح الموجه
الحمراء
لم تحصل ولكن هذا لا يعني ابدا ان اداره
الرئيس بايجن حره اليدين او باستطاعتها ان
همم تمضي في اجننتتها خاصه على المستوى
الداخلي الاقتصادي لان اليوم التوقعات
تشير انه بالرغم من عدم حصول موجه حمراء
ولكن الحزب الجمهوري سوف يحصل على غالبيه
صحيح غالبيه قصيره في مجلس النواب اليوم
مجلس شيوخ همم اصبحت حتى سيطرت الحزب
الديمقراطي باغلبيه صوت واحد على الاقل
بانتظار النتائج الرسميه هذا يعطي الرئيس
بيضا من امكانيه حصول تحقيقات بشانه لان
من يامر بهذه التحقيقات عاده هو مجلس
الشيوخ ولكن تبقى الماضي الى الاساسيه كيف
سوف يستطيع ان يمرر قوانين هو بحاشا اليها
لتنفيذ اجننتته
الاقتصاديه خاصه يعني على المستوى الداخلي
ان لم يحصل على الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
كما هو همم متوقع
وبالتالي يعني هذا يطرح علامات استفهام
هلا بالنسبه
لهذه النتائج وبالنسبه
للتوقعات تحول همم
هناك الرئاسيه المقبله يعني هنالك استطلاع
للراي همم جرى من قبل تيردوي وهو احد
مراكز البحوث همم الملفت فيه ان اغلبيه
الامريكيين لا يريدون ان يدخل السباق لا
الرئيس ترامب ولا الرئيس
كما يعني لان هذه النتائج التي تكلمنا
عنها حصلت رغم تدني يعني مستوى شعبيه
الرئيس في الانتخابات ولكن
الجمهوريون لم يحسنوا قياده الحمله
الانتخابيه خاصه في مساله
استقطاب الصوت النساء وصوت الشباب مساله
الاجهاض كان لها ثقها في عمليه
يعني اليوم اليوم همم يقول من ان هذه
النتيجه عزت من وضع السياسي اضافه الى ان
هناك من من يقول على الحزب الجمهوري يعني
يدرك همم ما هيته ووضع الان هذا هذه
النتيجه نتيجه الانتخابات يوم الخامس عشر
قد يطرح همم دونالد ترامب نفسه كمرشح
رئاسي رغم همم الخلافات داخل الحزب
الجمهوري الى اين يمكن ان يقودنا ذلك
بالمشهد الامريكي هذا سوف يقود ان حصل الى
تعمير الانقسام الداخلي في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه همم وبالتالي لا اعتقد
ان هذا سوف يعزز فرص الحزب الجمهوري
بالحصول همم يعني بالفوز بالانتخابات
المقبله يعني عاده حينما يخسر همم حزب مع
الانتخابات يعني يعيد ويركز على همم اعاده
همم اعاده النظر بسياسات الاساسيه
اليوم وفق المراقبين على الحزن الجمهوري
انه ركز اكثر من المطلوبه على ما سماه
سرقه الانتخابات من معتبره قاعده ناخبه
كبيره انه يعني تشكيك بالديمقراطيه
الامريكيه اليوم هنالك ايضا يعني هذه
الانتخابات اظهرت بروز وجوه جديده قيادات
جديده
يعني هذا ما سوف نراه في المرحله المقبله
مثلا من فاز في ولايه فلوريدا روندس
بيفوز كبير هو من الوجوه المرشح لقياده
الحزب الجمهوري في المعركه الرئاسيه
المقبله ولكن هل سوف يتحدق قرار الرئيس
ترامب ان اعلن همم نيته في الترشح في 15
من الشهر من الشهر الشهري يعني هذا همم
سؤال مهم وهتم اليوم يشد امطار المراقبين
يا خبر بفلوس مثل ما يقولون يومين ونعرف
النتيجه شكرا جزيلا لاستاد العلاقه
الدوليه الدكتور ساميه نادر شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الاوكرانيه
القوات الروسيه دمرت البنيه التحتيه
الرئيسيه في مدينه خيرسون بالجنوبيه
اوكرانيا قبيله الانسحاب ووصف المعارك
بانها كلب جحيم في منطقه
الشرقيه
وبدات الشرطه في اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
لتحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه خبراء
المتفجرات لدينا لديهم الكثير من العمل في
كل مكان في المنطقه المحرره ولقد تمت
ازالتهما يقرب من 2000 ماده متفجره تشمل
الالغامه والذخيره دمر المحتلون جميع
البناء التحتيه الحيويه بما فيها قطاع
الاتصالات وامدادات المياه والتدفئه
والكهرباء
اعلنتا سلطات الاوكرانيه حاله تاهب
للتحذير من الغارات الجويه في عده مناطق
بما في ذلك العاصمه كيف تستهدف روسيا
بضرباتها منشات الطاقه والصناعات الدفاعيه
والقياده العسكريه ومرافق الاتصالات في
جميع انحاء اوكرانيا وفي وقت سابق قال
الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ان حوالي 40% من البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه في اوكرانيا قد تضررت
نتيجه هذه الضربات
افادت سلطات خيرسون الانفصاليه بان القوات
الروسيه مازالت تسيطر على نسبه 70 بالمئه
من اراضي المقاطعه التي تحد نهر دنبرو من
الناحيه الشماليه بدورها اكدت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه صدها هجمات جويه اوكرانيه
على بعد عشرات الكيلومترات من نهر النيبرو
مشيرتا الى احباطها هجوما اخر في اليمن
تكبد فيها القوات الاوكرانيه خسائر كبيره
منها مقتل 90 جنديا
معنى مندوس كام مراسل العربيه رائد الاخضر
ومن كيف معنى صحفي محمد البابا نبدا مع
رغده رائد عفوا اولا رائد الى اين يمكن ان
نقول بان القوات المواليه لروسيا تسيطر
بالفعل على 70 بي ال 100 من الاراضي ما
الذي تركته بانسحابها القوات الروسيه في
خير سون
صباح الخير عادل لك ولكل المتابعين بالفعل
هناك انسحاب تكتيكي حسب التصريحات الرسميه
للدفاع الروسيه من الضفه الجنوبيه لنهار
دينيرو نهر دي نيرو الذي يمتد من مناطق في
بلاروسيا يمر في كييف وشيرنجه وسومي وعده
مناطق تقع على الضفه الشماليه يرى
المحللون والخبراء بان هناك خطه كبيره
لروسيا بعد ان بدات بتدمير الجسور التي
تصل ضفتي النهر
لقطعه الامدادات العسكريه ليس عن منطقه
خرسون او وحدها الامدادات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه اقصد عادل بل على كل هذا
المحور يعني تمتد لاكثر من
1000 كم همم مرورا بهذه المدن والمقاطعات
الكبيره همم نعرف بان روسيا ايضا ح على
اطراف بيلاروسيا
قوات عسكريه كبيره هناك خطط لم يعلن عنها
الجيش الروسي حتى الان لكن ننتظر الايام
القادمه سنرى همم يعني ما ما هي همم الخطه
الحقيقيه لهذا الانسحاب من منطقه خرسون
لكنها بالتاكيد مرتبطه بالعزل العسكري
للقوات الاوكرانيه التي تقاتل على الضفه
الشماليه من نهر النيل انت نفسك انت على
هذا النهر اذكر همم تعلم كيف هي الاحوال
هناك
هذه العمليات الروسيه من انها تدمر الجسور
هي لقطع الامداد لعدم همم تمكن او لعدم
ترك المجال للقوات الاوكرانيه من عبور هذه
الجسور وبالتالي الوصول الى قوات موجوده
اصلا همم في الجانب الاخر
بالضبط عادل تعلم بان الدعم الغربي للقوات
الاوكرانيه منصات الصواريخ صواريخ هايبرز
والمدافع اييه ام تربل سفن الدعم الغربي
غير مسار المعارك بشكل كبير
ورجحت الكفه لصالح الجيش الاوكراني الى حد
ما مع يعني تباين باعداد المقاتلين اعداد
المقاتلين الاوكرانيين اكبر واكثر بكثير
من المقاتلين الروسيا لجات الى هذا الخيار
وهو عزل الامدادات عن القوات الاوكرانيه
التي تقاتل داخل الخط او على الضفه
الشماليه من نهر دنبرو لكن المعارك اسمح
لي عادل ما زالت مستمره وقوات الروسيه
تقصف على بعد على الضفه الجنوبيه
تمركزات عسكريه
للجيش الاوكراني ساعود اليك لكن دعني اذهب
الى كيف هذه المره معنا ان هناك الصحفي
محمد البابا اهلا بك همم سيد البابا يعني
اليوم حينما نتحدث انه كيف تحتفل بتحرير
الستينا من منطقه همم في همم خيرسون هل هو
نصر معنوي ام انه ربما حاسم في سير هذه
المعركه
نعم بالفعل عادل يعني يمكن الجوله لما حصل
في مدينه كرسون والاستقبال والى حد الماء
المفاجئ من سكان مدينه قيسون للقوات
الاخرانيه يؤكد مقبوله ان اوكرانيا ستقوم
بتحرير كامل اراضيها التي تم احتلالها
ولكن لماذا جاء هذا الامتحان في هذا
التوقيت
كيف حصل الجيش الاوكراني ومنذ ان بدا
عمليه الهجوم المضاد في شمالي وشرقي
وشنوبي اوكرانيا قامت القوات الاوكرانيه
بعد ما حصل كما ذكر يعني زميلنا على رائد
حصلت على منظومه في مصر كان الجيش اوكراني
يكون بضرب خطوط الامداد للقوات الروسيه
جيش الاوكراني دمر الجسور التي كانت تعبر
من الضفه الشرقيه الى الضفه الغربيه الى
نهر النيل حيث مواجهه الجيش الاوكراني
خلال اربع او خمس اسابيع كان يتقدم ويحكم
يعني الاطباق على المناطق التي تصيطر
عليها روسيا في الضفه الغربيه
والان على ابواب فصل الشتاء خطوط الامداد
تصبح الى حد ما اكثر صعوبه للقوات الروسيه
لامداد القوات التي تقع في الضفه الغربيه
والتي تعتبر عسكريا هي منطقه ساقطه لانها
تحت مرمى الصواريخ والمدافع الاوكرانيه
وخاصه المدافع هاوتر وصواريخ لذلك التراجع
كما سمته روسيه هو تكتيكي ولكن جاء لان
يعني المرحله المقبله سيكون هناك صعوبه
للقوات الروسيه وايضا سيكون هناك هجوم
وستغل اوكرانيا هذا يعني التفوق لعدد
الكبير اوكرانيا
روسيا تقول من انها يعني احبطت هجوما في
همم الايمان كبد القوات الاوكرانيه تسعينا
همم
مقتل 90 جندي وبالتالي روسي يتقدم في شمال
رغم انها تنسحب في الجنوب هل هل تم تكتيك
هل تمت همم كيف تقرا كيف هذا الامر
في سير المعارك
لمن ومحيط لمن هي تقعدون المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه المعارك
الاساسيه الان في محيط مدينه باخمون هناك
قاره بين القوات الاوكرانيه تقوم القوات
الروسيه والانفصاليه بالهجوم وفي محاوله
للتقدم ثم يقوم الجيش الاوكراني بهجوم
مضاد لابعاده واكثر يعني اكثر طبيعه
المعارك تبادل
وما دفع الهاون في تلك المنطقه في المنطقه
الاخرى تعتبر قريبه من مدينه وهو محور
ايضا هناك معارض
شرسه وكما وصف رئيس الاوكراني هناك
محاولات من الطرفين الجاني
يحاولون التقدم في مناطق اخرى وتستخدم
بالدفاعات الاوكرانيه الوضع المعارك وخطوط
الجبهات هي على حالها لا تتغير للقوات
الاوكرانيه تقدمت في قطاع الجمباز ولا
القوات الروسيه تتقدم في قطاع الجمباز
هناك يعني محاولات من الطرفين حتى هذه
اللحظه في جنوب
التراجعت وذلك تكتيكيا لان المرحله
المقبله ستكون قاسيه وهناك ضعف في امدادات
العسكريه واللوجستيه للجيش الروسي الجيش
الروسي بعد عمليه التعبئه
يعني باقل من دقيقه رائد هل الناحيه
الشماليه يعني الدنيا هل تم تحصينات روسيه
في هذه المنطقه خوفا من اي هجوم مستقبلك
بدايه عادل وبعجال دعني اقول عن المحور
لدينا هنا في دانيسك وهي مساله هامه
بالفعل القوات
المواليه لروسيا سيطرت على بلده بابلوكا
على اطراف اوغلودار في الناحيه الجنوبيه
من مقاطعه دينيس وتقود معارك ضاريه على
اطراف مارينكا وافديفكا القوات الروسيه
الاحتياطيه او بعد تعبئه الجزئيه وصلت
بشكل تدريجي نرى اعداد كبيره من الجنود
الروس الذين يحضرونا هنا الى المقاطعه
ويقاتلون على محاور كثيره
وكما اسلفت محور همم حيث الايمان
وكبيانس هناك ضرب للقوات الاوكرانيه من
قبل الجيش الروسي بشكل يومي صباح اليوم
اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه عن قتل اكثر من 300
جندي اوكراني في هذا المحلات طيب رائد
الاخبر مراسل العربيه من دون ناس شكرا
جزيلا لك وكذلك شكر منصور للصحفي محمد
البابا من كيف
اتهما وزير الخارجيه الروسيه سيرجي
لابروفا الولايات المتحده وحلف شمال
الاطلسي بمحاوله السيطره على منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئه من خلال مواصفات المنطقه
واضاف في كلمته امام قمه الاسيان في
كمبوديا ان نيته يلعب دور رائدا في تهديد
امن منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادي واكد
لافروف وعدم التوصل لبيان مشترك في قمه
اسيان بسبب تضمنه لغه غير مقبوله من
واشنطن على حد تعبيره مضيفا في الوقت ذاته
ان روسيا ترفض تقييمات واشنطن حول الوضع
في اوكرانيا
مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
فرنسا تتهم ايطاليا بعدم احترام القانون
الدولي بسبب ازمه سفينه اوشن باكينغ
[موسيقى]
بعد غزوه بدر
بنفسه كان متاكدا بانه خطير ليقود المانيا
للسيطره على العالم وبعد فشل مفاوضاته مع
موسكو قرر اجتياحها وثائقي يروي قصه اكبر
غزو بري في التاريخ
المراحل المختلفه للعمليه
صعود النازيه
الجمعه الواحده بعد منتصف الليل على شاشه
العربيه
كل يوم يطل علينا
يفتح امامنا افاقا جديده
نلتقي ننطلق نحو المستقبل
[موسيقى]
مواضيعها
انسانيه
اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض
يقدمه من خلال اخبار السعوديه والخليج
الرابعه نشرتكم
يوميا على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله اعتبر عضو البرلمان البريطاني
بوب بلاك مان استدعاء الحكومه البريطانيه
للسفير الايراني بخصوص تهديد الصحفيين في
المملكه المتحده انه لا يكفي بلاك من ده
عائله طردي جميع الدبلوماسيين الايرانيين
بالاضافه الى وضع الحرس الثوري باكمله على
قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه جاء ذلك بعد ما
اعلن وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفر
القائم بالاعمال الايرانيه بعد تعرض
الصحفيين يعملون في بريطانيا لتهديدات
مباشره على حياتهم من النظام الايراني
قبل ذلك قالت الحكومه الفرنسيه ان اثنين
اخرين من مواطنيها محتجزان في ايران ما
يجعل العدد الاجمالي للمواطنين الفرنسيين
المحتجزين لدى طهران سبعه اشخاص بدوره
اعرب وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاثرين
كولونا عن قلقها بشان استمرار احتجاز
السلطات الايرانيه لمواطنين فرنسيين
كولونا اكدت انه اذا كان هدف ايران من هذه
الاعمال هو الابتزاز فعليها ان تعلم انها
اختارت الطريق الخطا في مواجهه فرنسا وافق
تعبيرها
في غضون ذلك دعا ناشطون ايرانيون الى
زياده الضغط على النظام والتنظيم تظاهرات
في عده مدن بحلول الخامس عشر من نوفمبر
الجاري وذلك بالتزامني مع مرور ذكرى حمله
قمع المحتجين في مظاهرات ارتفاع اسعار
الوقود دعوه مضاعفه المظاهرات الايرانيه
جاءت عبر منصات التواصل لاحياء ذكرى 1500
قتيل في تظاهرات عام
2019 في الوقت الذي تشهد ايران موجه
احتجاجات متصاعده بالداخل والخارج رغما عن
تهديدات السلطات
كشف مسؤول ايرانيه ان بلاده خسرت 450
مليار دولار خلال السنوات العشر الماضيه
بسبب الحظر النفطي نتيجه العقوبات التي
تفرضها الولايات المتحده على طهران ونقلته
وكاله ايستنا عن رئيس لجنه الطاقه والبيئه
في غرفه تجاره طهران قوله ان ايران تحتل
المرتبه الاولى في الاستهلاك الطاقه في
العالم
هددت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كولونا
ايطاليا بمواجهه عواقب حاله استمرار
اسرارها على رفض استقبال سفينه اللاجئين
متهمه روما بعدم احترام القانون الدولي
والقانون البحري كولونا اوضحت ايضا ان
فرنسا اوقفت اليه نقل اللاجئين من ايطاليا
وزادت الرقابه على الحدود الفرنسيه
الايطاليه
بالعوده الى لندن والخبر هناك من لندن
الباحث فيها شان الايراني وجدان عبد
الرحمن ينضم الينا سيد عبد الرحمن اهلا بك
بدايه لي ان اتحدث عن هذه الدعوه لبلاكمان
عضو البرلمان البريطاني هل من الممكن ان
يحدث شيء هل من الممكن ان تتجه الحكومه
البريطانيه الى التصعيد مع طهران
تحياتي لك استاذه علي الوائلي متابعيك
الكرام
هذه هي تعد خطوه
ايجابيه بالنسبه لهذا الملف لكن استبعد في
الوقت الحالي انه بريطانيا تقدم على هكذا
خطوه ان تقوم بادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني على قائمه العقوبات البريطانيه
او انها تتخذ
قرارات اشاد ضد الحكومه الايرانيه لكن طرح
هذا الموضوع وله اهميه كبيره خاصه
النظام الايراني بدا يهدد ايضا سمعنا
اخبار الصحف الايرانيه ايضا
ستكون هنالك بعض العمليات في همم داخل
بريطانيا تستهدف مواطنين بريطانيين من
اصول ايرانيه وهذا وهذا ما اقدمت النظام
الاي على هكذا خطوات بكل تاكيد ستخذ
بريطانيا قرارات اكثر همم
حزمه وضغط على النظام الايراني خاصه ونحن
نعرف انه بريطانيا في مجال همم
الامن لا تتهاون مع ليس فقط ايران وانما
مع اي انظمه في العالم لانه موضوع همم
حمايه المواطنين في بريطانيا مهم جدا
وسيكون رده فعل قاسيه من بريطانيا الى
الفعل ما خدمت ايران على هكذا خطوات خاصه
وانها بدات تهدد على على بالنهار ستستهدف
صحافيين في القنوات
الفارسيه او ان الشيطان همم من اصول
ايرانيه في بريطانيا طيب هذه هذه التهديد
يعني هل فقط سيقف عند استدعاء القائم
بالاعمال الايرانيه ام قد تتطور الامور
يعني اليوم
بكل تاكيد يعني استدعاء السفير هو يترتب
عليه الكثير من المسؤوليات وعلى
النظيف تفسير هذه
التهديدات واذا ما اقامت ايران بالفعل
بتنفيذ
تهديداتها في بريطانيا بكل تاكيد الامر
يتصاعد بشكل اكبر و ايضا قد يؤدي الى حتى
طرد همم طرد المندوبين الايرانيين في
السفاره الايرانيه وهذا ما
اشارت اليه بعض الدول الاوروبيه انه في
حال استمر النظام الايراني بتهديدات ستكون
هنالك ردات فعلا من الدول الغربيه
بطرد همم السفراء وايضا مندوبيه الحكومه
الايرانيه في السفارات الغربيه شكرا للي
يا سيده وجدان عبد الرحمن باحث في شان
الايراني
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصلنا
رئيس مجلس اسياد السوداني يحذر من استمرار
انقسام القوه السياسيه وغياب التوافق
حياكم الله اكد رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان ان مهمه
الجيش الاولى هي حمايه الوطن والشعب
السوداني كما تعاهد البرهان بتحقيق تطلعات
السودانيين للوصول الى تغيير الحقيقي وليس
مصطنعا وحضر البرهان من استمرار انقسام
القوه السياسيه وغياب التوافق
مع الشعب السوداني في انه ينال مبتغاه
وينال مخرج من اجله من اجل تغيير حقيقي
تغيير ما مصطنع تغيير ما فيهم اي جهه
كسبانه غير هذا الشعب
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان الجيش
الصيني اطلق 36 طائره مقاتله وقذفات قناه
بالقرب من الجزيره ونددت الوزاره بالترهيب
العسكريه الصينيه الذي ياتي في اطار حمله
طويله الامل تستهدف الجزيره التي تتمتع
بالحكم الذاتي والتي تؤكد بالتين انها جزء
من اراضيها واوضحت الوزاره ان 10 طائرات
حلقت فوق الخط الاوسط في مضيقي تايوان
الذي يفصل الجزيره عن البر الرئيسي الصيني
يلتقي غدا الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
بنظيره الصيني في جيم بنك قبيله انعقاد
قمه مجموعه العشرين في اندونيسيا في
اجتماع يعدل اول منذ تولي بيض الرئاسه
واعرب بيض عن مخاوفه من الانشطه القتاليه
البحريه الصينيه في بحر الصين الجنوبي
واكد بيض انه سيسعى الى تحديد الخطوط
الحمره في العلاقات مع بكين خلال محادثات
مع نظيره الصيني قبل ذلك اوضح مستشار
الرئيس الامريكي ان لقاء بيدن بشي جيم بنك
سيحدده سقف العلاقه بين البلدين ياتي ذلك
مع تصاعدي التوترات بين واشنطن وبكين حول
قضايا رئيسيه ابرزها تايوان واوكرانيا
بالاضافه الى المسائل الاقتصاديه
والتجاريه الاخرى
معنى من بكينا صحفيه النادر رونج سيد نادر
اهلا بك يعني
اي الملفات ستكون في المقدمه همم ملف
تايوان اوكرانيا ام الملف الاقتصادي في
المحادثات بين الرئيس الصيني ونظير
الامريكي
قمه مجموعه العشرين وهي اا المناسبه
للتعاون الاقتصادي هناك
التعامل اقتصادي وكيفيه الدفع الانتعاش
الاقتصاد العالمي واا كذلك همم بعده ساجده
تواجه حسين يعني مواقيتها الواضحه اتجاه
الكثير من القضايا التي همم لها الخلاف مع
الولايات المتحده
فاعتقدوا
[موسيقى]
الاجتماعات اتصال بينهما قد يريد البلد
على هذه الى اين تتجه او الى اي السقف من
الممكن ان تصل
العلاقه بين واشنطن وبكين
اعتقد في هذا لقاءه يتم النقاش
يعني
اداره الخلافات بشكل مناسب
ويعني تقليل يعني همم توسعه ان يتعاقد
تعاون الرقم موجود الخلافات
كل الاتصال وتنسيق بين الولايات المتحده
والصين سي ساهم في استقرار المنطقه وكذلك
السلام والاستقرار في العالم كله
نعم سيد نادر شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من
بكين نادر روك
اذا سنذهب الى ناصر الطيبي واخبار
الاقتصاد
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك عادل اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
اذا تحديث لي ارقام الجلسه في تداولات هذا
اليوم بعد ان كنا قد شاهدنا في اللحظات
الاولى افتتاح السوق السعوديه بقفزه قويه
بواحد فاصل ثلاثه في المئه تخف الان
المكاسب الى اقل من نصف النقطه المئويه
كان المؤشر قد تجاوز 11,000 و350 نقطه قبل
ان يعود للانخفاض دون 11,000 و300 نقطه
معظم الاسواق في المنطقه العامله اليوم
باستثناء السقي الامارات على ارتفاع تحسن
طبعا في شهيه اخذ المخاطره في ظل القراءه
الاخيره لمؤشر اسعار المستهلكين التضخم في
الولايات المتحده يوم الخميس مساء والذي
جاءت اقل من المتوقع بالتالي الاسواق الان
تحتسب وتره التشدد في نسب الفائده
الامريكيه قد تكون اقل من ما كانت تتخوف
منه سابقا مجموعه تدا تتراجع ب 9% الى ما
دون السعر الذي تخارجت منه او تخرج منه
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه من حصه 10%
اضافيه في مجموعه تداول باعتها على سعر
191 ريال وهو اا يقدر بخصم سعره ب 9% عن
اغلاق يوم الخميس بالتالي شهدنا عمليات
بيع قويه على هذا السهم الذي ينخفض الى ما
دون سعر همم تخارج الصندوق عند ال 191
ريال المعمر على ارتفاع بثلاث ارباع
النقطه المئويه مع تجديد لتسهيلات
ائتمانيه متوافقه مع الشريعه قيمتها 150
مليون ريال الى يونيو من العام المقبل
سلوشنز توقع على همم عرض ملزم للاستحواذ
على كامل حصص اس تي سي وشركه اي اس ام
القبضه في شركه مراكز الاتصال سي سي بصفقه
تقدر باكثر من 400 مليون ريال على
الارتفاع 19
قويه همم طبعا هذه نظره على بعض الاسهم
القياديه سابك على مكاسب نصف النقطه 84
ريال و30 هلله معادن مكاسب بواحد ونصف
النقطه المئويه معظم البنوك ايضا كذلك على
ارتفاع هذا اليوم باستثناء استقرار على
الراجحي وعلى الجزيره مكاسب الاهلي
باثنين% واخيرا في قطاع الاتصالات تعذيب ب
6% مكاسب وموبايلي مكاسب بنصف النقطه
المئويه السوق الكويتيه المؤشر الكويت
الاول على ارتفاع بواحد في المئه همم
وطبعا هذه نظره على الاسهم القياديه مكاسب
لشمال الزور بواحد في المئه ببيان البترو
كما كنز ايضا بنصف النقطه المئويه والبنوك
على ارتفاع بيتك لاحظه مكاسب باثنين وربع
النقطه المئويه هذه كانت مشاهدينا اذا
وقفتنا مع اسواق المنطقه التي تبدا على
ارتفاع بعد الارتفاعات القويه التي
شاهدتها وول ستريت يوم الخميس والجمعه بعد
بيانات تضخم الاتجاهات قل من المتوقع عوده
الان من جديد اليك عاده ما يجي منك الخير
والارتفاع ان شاء الله يسلمك هذا بوجودك
تسلم
[موسيقى]
اعلن ملكه تويتر الجديد ورئيسها التنفيذي
الى الماس كان قرار العلامه الزرقاء
للحساب الموثق على موقع تويتر سيتخدع
سيتخذ على الارجح نهايه الاسبوع المقبل
وكان ماسك اعلى لنا في وقت سابق ان الشركه
ستفرض رسوما قدرها ثمانيه دولارات شهريا
مقابل خدمه علامه التحقق الزرقاء وقال
ماسك ان المشتركين الذين لديهم علامات
التحقق الزرقاء سيحصلون على الاولويه في
الردود والاشارات والبحث وسيكونون قادرين
على نشر مقاطع فيديو وتسجيلات الصوتيه
اطول كما سيشاهدون نصف عدد الاعلانات
شكرا لكم لطيب المتابعه واترككم في رعايه
الله وحبه في امان الكريم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]